es ist eine woche her dass im hafen von
beirut um 18 uhr nachts ortszeit 2750
tonnen ammoniumnitrat explodierten die
halbe stadt ist zerstört ebenso wie die
libanesische gesellschaft die libanesen
sie demonstrieren seit der katastrophe
auch gewaltsam um ein politisches system
abzuschaffen
dass solch eine katastrophe überhaupt
erst einmal ermöglichte die gesamte
regierung ist mittlerweile
zurückgetreten
die proteste gehen aber weiter wir sehen
hier live bilder die uns erreichen in
diesen minuten eine zentrale trauerfeier
in beirut die stattfindet zur
unglückszeit zehntausende wollen am
hafen der opfer gedenken und für uns
beobachtet sebastian bringe diese
trauerveranstaltungen im hafen von
beirut christian vii ist sehr sebastian
wie sie derzeit abgelaufen
moritz zehntausend menschen haben sich
am ground zero der katastrophe
versammelt um 18 uhr könnte dann der
gong dann sind die namen der 160 opfer
verlesen worden
dazu wurden auf einer videoleinwand die
bilder der explosion abgespielt die
menschen haben gebeten menschen haben
geweint
viele hatten papiertüten dabei darin der
schutz der häuser in denen die opfer ums
leben gekommen sind wir haben aber nicht
nur szenen der trauer gesehen auch der
mut viele trauernde hatten zeigen dabei
daran hingen die politiker als puppen
ein deutliches zeichen an die
mittlerweile zurückgetretene regierung
das hat man auch auf pappschildern lesen
können auf denen stand wir werden den
anführern niemals verteilen und wie geht
es denn nun weiter im land du hast es
gesagt die regierung ist zurückgetreten
die proteste gehen aber weiter auch für
heute abend werden ja wieder proteste
erwartet was fordern denn die menschen
konkret jetzt im land naja also wie du
schon sagtest es gab ja in den
vergangenen tagen heftige
straßenschlachten die demonstranten
haben
aus dem amt gejagt aber das reichte
ihnen nicht die sind wirklich wütend auf
die politiker man kann einfach nur
hoffen dass beirut jetzt langsam zur
ruhe kommt es wird eine neue regierung
gewählt ob dann alles besser wird das
muss man abwarten das kann man jetzt
noch nicht sagen aber immerhin neuwahlen
bedeuten bestimmt auch neue hoffnung für
die menschen irgendwie wandern